This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是有电梯可用时依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个奇怪的现代世界里，我将剖析心理韧性、体能训练以及培养复原力的秘诀。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上搜索数字“2”和英文单词percent收听。欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。从1979年开始，这对我是个重大时刻。84年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同仁喜剧演员以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如讨论80年代的马克·拉蒙特·希尔。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就非得这么做。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试动过一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. We are doing a fun episode today, something a little bit different than what we normally do, but I promise we are definitely not skipping any of the psychology behind this week's topic. And that topic is how to have better first dates in your 20s. I think dating in our 20s, let's not kid ourselves, feels like a little bit of a mind field because there is no right or wrong way to do it. And honestly, a lot of people don't really know what they want. They don't know what they like. They don't know what they're looking for.
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，和我们一起剖析20多岁的心理学。今天我们要做一个有趣的节目，跟我们平时的风格有点不一样，但我保证，我们绝对没有忽略本周主题背后的任何心理学知识。这个主题就是：如何在20多岁时拥有更好的第一次约会。我觉得在20多岁时约会，咱们别自欺欺人了，感觉就像一个雷区，因为没有对或错的方法来做这件事。说实话，很多人其实并不真正知道自己想要什么。他们不知道自己喜欢什么。他们不知道自己在寻找什么。
It feels like there are a million choices out there, and yet no one, no one available, no one left single at the same time. And then there is the actual act of going on the dates. Also sometimes a nightmare, especially first dates when you don't really know someone beyond maybe a couple of messages. Often a lot of us find it easier to just not go, to just not deal with the hassle, then have to sit through another person telling us about their job and their work and their favourite colour. But I also have a different perspective for you. I think dating, especially in our
感觉外面有数百万种选择，然而却没有一个人，没有一个单身的人是同时处于可约会状态的。然后就是实际去约会的行为。有时也是一场噩梦，尤其是第一次约会，除了可能发过几条信息之外，你对某人并不真正了解。通常我们很多人会觉得干脆不去，不用应付这些麻烦，比起不得不坐在那里听另一个人向我们讲述他们的工作、他们的职业和他们最喜欢的颜色要容易得多。但我对你们有不同的看法。我认为约会，尤其是在你的
20s, is meant to be fun, is meant to give you good stories. And I truly believe that going on dates, seeing what you like and don't like the kind of people that are out there is actually going to help you learn so much more about yourself. I will say for the record, I am very much in a relationship, the best relationship of my life. But before I met him, I went on, I think, more first dates than I can count. Some of them were wonderful. Some of them were absolutely terrible. Some of them were awkward and confusing. Like, we all have those horror stories, right? But I think despite all of that, I have never not had fun. I have never once left to date being like, that was a waste of my time. Because my mindset towards dating, first,
20多岁时，本该是充满乐趣的，本该为你提供精彩的故事。我坚信，去约会，看看你喜欢和不喜欢什么，了解外面都是什么样的人，实际上会帮你更深入地了解你自己。我得说句公道话，我确实在恋爱中，这是我一生中最棒的恋爱。但在遇到他之前，我经历过的第一次约会多到数不清，我想。其中有些非常美好。有些简直糟糕透顶。有些则尴尬又令人困惑。就像，我们都有那些恐怖故事，对吧？但我认为尽管经历了这一切，我从来没有觉得不开心。我从来没有哪一次约会结束后觉得“那是浪费我的时间”。因为我对约会的态度，首先是
dates in particular is that no matter what they think, no matter what the outcome is, no matter whether this person is the one, you are there for an experience and nothing more. And I've learned a few things about how to have really amazing first dates, ones that are memorable and exciting and sweet and most of all just really, really fun. So for all of you out there in the trenches of single life and dating right now. Maybe you've just hit a bad run of awful dates. You're never getting asked on second dates. You're not actually enjoying yourself
尤其是对第一次约会，不管对方怎么想，不管结果如何，不管这个人是不是真命天子，你到那里去是为了体验，仅此而已。关于如何拥有真正精彩的第一次约会，我学到了一些经验，那些让人难忘、激动、甜蜜，最重要的是真的、真的很有趣的约会。所以，所有正身处单身生活和约会水深火热之中的朋友们。也许你刚刚经历了一连串糟糕的约会。你从来没有被邀请进行第二次约会。你其实并不享受这个过程，
and you're beginning to really like question whether this is a waste of your time. This episode is for you. I've got 10 tips for you. And let me say this first, take this advice or leave it. Some of this is practical. It may not apply to you. But also, regardless of what anyone says,
并且你开始真正地质疑这是否是在浪费你的时间。这一期节目就是为你准备的。我有10个小建议要送给你。首先声明，这些建议听不听由你。其中一些很实用。可能并不适合你。而且，不管别人怎么说，
and that includes myself, the most important factor is, you know, not formulaic. It's not based on how you dress. It's not based on how many good stories you tell how much you drink where you're going, the location. The key to really good first dates is just your authenticity. Someone who is confident in who they are, regardless of whether someone else likes them back, regardless of whether someone else thinks they're attractive or funny or intelligent, whatever. You're always going to have more success and have better first states or at least be more discerning if you are confident and if you know what you're looking for.
包括我自己在内，最重要的因素是，你知道的，它不是公式化的。它不是基于你穿什么。它不是基于你讲了多少个精彩的故事，你喝了多少酒，你要去哪里，也就是地点。真正好的第一次约会的关键只是你的真实。一个对自己充满信心的人，不管别人是否也喜欢他们，不管别人是否认为他们有吸引力、有趣、聪明，无论如何。如果你有自信，并且知道自己在寻找什么，你总会取得更多的成功，拥有更好的第一次约会，或者至少会有更好的辨别力。
That's because I think A, you're not pretending to be someone that you're not and therefore you're not expending all of this energy into a character or a persona. You know, you want to actually find someone who likes you for you if you're looking for longevity and you're not going to get that by putting on an act because you won't be comfortable, you won't feel secure. And B, I think authenticity is also attractive. It is the most attractive part of a person, their own self-assurance and who they are where they belong, the treatment they deserve. Not everyone is going to be the love of your life. There will be some bad eggs, some kind of frogs that you have to kiss, but they are just part of the story, I think. That's what I always say, the tapestry of your 20s and who cares if they're not the
这是因为我认为，A，你没有假装成不是你自己的人，因此你没有把所有的精力都消耗在一个角色或面具上。你知道的，如果你在寻找长久的关系，你其实是想找到一个真正喜欢你本色的人，而你不会通过假装来得到这一点，因为你不会感到舒适，你不会感到安全。B，我认为真实也是很有吸引力的。它是一个人身上最具吸引力的部分，他们对自己的自信，他们是谁，他们属于哪里，他们应得的待遇。不是每个人都会成为你生命中的挚爱。会有一些烂苹果，一些你不得不吻的丑青蛙，但它们只是故事的一部分，我认为。这就是我常说的，你20多岁的人生织锦，谁在乎他们是不是真命天子呢，
one, they give you something interesting to talk about because right now, I think especially during this decade, you should be the love of your life. The relationship you have with yourself is the most important one you are ever going to have, ever. So it's not worth compromising that just to receive the validation or acceptance of someone you really don't know that well. I also think dating is a bit of a game. It's a skill more than anything else, something that we get better at over time. So what are some of the ways that we can have better? of first dates from that perspective, from a psychological perspective as well. How can we really
他们给了你一些有趣的话题，因为现在，尤其是在这个十年里，你应该成为你生命中的挚爱。你与自己的关系是你将拥有的最重要的一段关系，永远都是。所以，为了获得你其实并不那么了解的某人的认可或接受，去妥协这一点是不值得的。我也觉得约会有点像一场游戏。与其说别的，不如说它是一项技能，是我们随着时间推移而变得越来越熟练的事情。那么，从这个角度、从心理学的角度来看，我们有哪些方法可以拥有更好的第一次约会呢？我们如何才能真正
feel our best, feel most charismatic, represent ourselves as best as we can and kind of be in our power, but also get what we want out of this experience. Well, I have all the tips from the scent you wear to the location you should choose, the nonverbal cues you should be putting out how to leverage the power of silence and suspense, all of that and more in this episode. So without further ado, let's get into my tips for having the best first dates in our 20s. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers,
展现出最好的自己，感到最具魅力，尽可能好地展现自我并保持掌控力，同时从这段经历中得到我们想要的呢？好吧，我准备了所有的建议，从你喷的香水到你应该选择的地点，你应该发出的非语言信号，如何运用沉默和悬念的力量，这些以及更多内容都在本期节目中。废话不多说，让我们进入我关于在20多岁时拥有最好第一次约会的建议吧。2%。这就是有电梯可用时依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、
researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple, Apple, podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等对话，抛弃那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊恐的许多问题其实都是压力导致的。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何平台上搜索字母T-W-O-Persent收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍了两次小金·姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金·姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们第二次讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年来
experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
在心理健康领域的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood,
而我们仍在追逐，却不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，
pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
因为你觉得在你活在世上时做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、为人父、
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试动过一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. First dates are honestly some of my favorite kinds of dates because they are both simultaneously low stakes and high stakes at the same time. And the energy that that brings, the sense of anticipation of anything can happen is exciting. It's really addictive. You could end the date and be like, yeah, not for me.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
I'm never going to see this person again. Or you can meet the love of your life on a rainy Monday night at an Italian place and suddenly all of those lost loves, all of those failed situationships, all of those heartbreaks no longer matter. But the trick here is twofold. First dates are going to be better when you go in with low expectations. So you take the low stakes approach. This is because it kind of leaves more space to be surprised.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。第一次约会坦白说是我最喜欢的约会类型之一，因为它们既同时具有低风险又具有高风险。由此带来的能量、任何事情都有可能发生的期待感令人兴奋。它真的很让人上瘾。你可能在约会快结束时说，是的，不适合我。
rather than disappointed. If you go into a date thinking, okay, this is it, we are going to talk for hours, they're going to confess their love for me instantly, I would say 99% of the time, that won't happen. And you'll feel like the date is a failure or a waste. But if you approach it with the perspective of, this is just one night of my life and I'm going to meet someone new, I'm going to get out of the house, at the very least it's practice, you know, the small things, are going to seem so much more exciting and you're more likely to have a better time. They've actually tested this theory, this low stakes, low expectations approach in a number of academic studies and one of these was using video games. So they showed that when people had
我再也不会见到这个人了。或者你可以在一个下雨的周一晚上在一家意大利餐厅遇到你的真命天子，突然之间，所有那些失去的爱恋、所有那些失败的暧昧关系、所有那些心碎都无关紧要了。但这里的诀窍有两个方面。当你抱着低期望值去的时候，第一次约会会更好。所以你采取低风险的方法。这是因为这留出了更多的空间去感到惊喜，
really high expectations of what they were about to experience, the game they were about to play, they actually enjoyed it a lot less than people who had no idea and were just kind of there to see and have fun. And the same goes for dates, right? Like high expectations often means unrealistic expectations, which means you're probably going to leave feeling a little bit defeated. Now, I think importantly there is a difference between lowering your expectations and lowering your standards. I think expectations are about whether someone is going to meet your standards. So the standards stay unchanged. We do not lower our standards. But how you kind of appraise someone
而不是感到失望。如果你带着这种想法去约会，好吧，就是这样了，我们要聊上好几个小时，他们会立刻向我倾诉爱意，我敢说99%的情况下，这都不会发生。你会觉得约会是一次失败或浪费。但如果你以“这只是我生活中的一个夜晚，我要去认识一个新朋友，我要出门走走，最起码这也是一种练习”的心态来对待它，你知道的，那些小事，
else's ability to meet those standards should remain low until they prove you otherwise. So I'm going to explain this a little bit further. Basically, don't walk into every first date thinking that every person has it in them to treat you the way you deserve to be treated. And if they don't have it in them, if they aren't the one, that is not a reflection of you, but of them. Once again, the standards remain unchanged, but the expectations are lowered. Secondly, you're not going to get what you want out of a first day or any kind of dating-like interaction unless you're clear on what you want. And maybe you don't know what you want, you just want to have fun, that is still an intention.
就会显得格外激动人心，你更有可能玩得开心。他们实际上在许多学术研究中测试过这个理论，这种低风险、低期望的方法，其中一项研究使用的是电子游戏。因此他们发现，当人们对即将体验的游戏抱有非常高的期望时，他们实际上比那些一无所知、只是去看看并找乐子的人要少得多地享受这个游戏。约会也是如此，对吧？高期望往往意味着不切实际的期望，这意味着你离开时可能会感到有点受挫。现在，我认为重要的是，降低期望和降低标准是有区别的。我认为期望是关于某人是否会达到你的标准。所以标准保持不变。我们不会降低我们的标准。但是你如何评估别人
I think we start to fear and avoid first days when we say that we want one thing and we actually expect something else. And I did a whole episode on this around dating with intention. And I think dating with intention doesn't necessarily mean that you're dating for commitment. Even if you're looking for something casual, that is totally fine. But what you need to be clear on is, is that actually what I want right now or am I lying to myself. Am I actually clear on my intentions here? Because I think if you go into a first day expecting, you know, to fall in love, but then you accept someone who does not have the
达到这些标准的能力，应该保持较低，直到他们向你证明并非如此。所以我将对此做进一步解释。基本上，不要带着这样的想法走进每一次第一次约会：每个人都有能力像你应得的那样对待你。如果他们没有这个能力，如果他们不是真命天子，那不是你的反映，而是他们的反映。再次强调，标准保持不变，但期望降低了。其次，除非你清楚自己想要什么，否则你无法从第一次约会或任何类似约会的互动中得到你想要的东西。也许你不知道自己想要什么，你只是想玩得开心，这仍然是一个意图。
same intentions because you're kind of engaging in a little bit of delusion, it's just not going to be enjoyable. There won't be a future there. I think setting your intentions up will also help you beyond just first dates, but also in terms of an entire perspective shift on dating and what you're looking for. And I think to understand what you're looking for, you have to be clear around three questions. What do I want from this date? What do I want from this person? What do I want in the near future? And if you answer those honestly, you really do set yourself up for success. Okay, we're going to go back to our practical tips here. You've already taken a low stakes approach. Congratulations. You best believe that you know what you want.
我认为当我们说我们想要一件事而实际上期待另一件事时，我们开始害怕并避开第一次约会。我围绕带着意图约会做了一整期节目。我认为带着意图约会并不一定意味着你是为了承恋爱关系而约会。即使你在寻找随意的关系，那也完全没问题。但你需要明确的是，这真的是我现在想要的吗？还是我在自欺欺人？我在这里的意图真的明确吗？因为我认为如果你带着期望去进行第一次约会，你知道的，期望坠入爱河，但随后你接受了一个没有相同意图的人，因为你有点在进行自我欺骗，这根本不会愉快。那里不会有未来。我认为设定意图不仅能帮到你第一次约会，还能帮你彻底改变对约会以及你在寻找什么的看法。而且我认为要明白你在寻找什么，你必须明确三个问题。我从这次约会中想要什么？我从这个人身上想要什么？我在不久的将来想要什么？如果你诚实地回答了这些，你确实为成功做好了准备。好吧，我们要回到我们的实用建议这里。你已经采取了低风险的方法。恭喜。你可以确信你知道自己想要什么。
Now we're going to look at first dates in three stages. The before, the during, and the after. And what kind of behaviours and habits in each of these stages is going to leave you feeling amazing each time, even if the person is, you know, I hate to say it, like a little bit of a loser, a little bit of a done. So before. Before the date, you are kind of in the process of courting this person. and maybe you have matched on a dating app or you met at a party a few weeks ago.
现在我们将从三个阶段来看待第一次约会。之前、期间和之后。以及在这些阶段中的每一种行为和习惯，如何能让你每次都感觉棒极了，即使这个人，你知道的，我讨厌这么说，有点像个失败者，有点无趣。所以在之前。在约会之前，你处于追求这个人的过程中。也许你们在约会软件上配对成功了，或者几周前在聚会上认识的。
Someone's like put you in touch. The sooner between that first connection and the first date, the better. Because you don't give yourself the time to, you know, kind of psych yourself out. You don't let your doubts sneak in. You don't waste your time. And you don't give yourself the chance to build up a fantasy image of this person in your head before actually getting to know them in real life. So I would say keep the texting to the minimum here.
有人把你介绍给对方。从第一次联系到第一次约会之间的时间越短越好。因为你没有给自己时间去，你知道的，自己吓自己。你不会让你的疑虑偷偷溜进来。你没有浪费时间。并且在真正在现实生活中了解这个人之前，你不会给自己机会在脑海中建立这个人的幻想形象。所以我建议把发短信保持在最低限度。
Make it plan directed. Something I always used to say when I was kind of on the apps is that I'm not looking for a pen pal. I'm not looking to chat with you for a month before we actually meet because compatibility and chemistry, they are only really fully recognizable and proven in person. So based on those psychological principles of attraction that we talk about all the time.
以计划为导向。我在用那些软件时经常说的一句话是，我不是在找笔友。我不是在找你聊上一个月才真正见面的人，因为兼容性和化学反应，它们只有在面对面时才能真正被完全识别和证明。因此，根据我们经常谈论的那些吸引力心理学原则，
We know that we are going to understand someone more like someone more when we leverage proximity. So actually being around them in person, not just familiarity that is brought through texting and such. So rule of thumb, one week of messaging and then someone has to make a move here. And that can be you. Just be like, hey, I have a question. when are you going to ask me out on a date? When are we going to go on a date? Get that online
我们知道，当我们利用邻近效应时，我们会更了解某人、更喜欢某人。所以实际上是亲自陪伴在他们身边，而不仅仅是通过发短信等带来的熟悉感。因此，经验法则，发一周的消息，然后就得有人采取行动了。那个人也可以是你。只要说，嘿，我有件事要问。你什么时候约我出去？我们什么时候去约会？把那个线上
interaction into a real world setting ASAP. My next tip is you pick the place. Something I think women in particular are afraid of doing is making an explicit move or being the one to plan and decide the date. I think we hear a lot around how we should expect someone else to take the lead because if they wanted to, they would. I think that's a great principle to hold, but honestly, and maybe this is controversial, I think that really feeds into some quite outdated norms on women needing to be led or feeling as if men get to call the shots
互动尽快变成现实世界的设置。我的下一个建议是，你来选地方。我认为尤其是女性害怕做的一件事就是采取明确的行动，或者成为计划和决定约会的人。我想我们经常听到很多关于我们应该期望别人带头的话，因为如果他们想的话，他们就会这么做。我认为这是一个很好的坚持原则，但老实说，也许这很有争议，我认为这确实助长了一些相当过时的规范，即女性需要被引导，或者觉得男性可以做决定，
or should be in control of kind of romantic instances, of like romantic connection. Maybe you like the effort, I don't know, I feel like that's also totally fine, but I am a firm believer that even if they picked the date and the time, you pick the place. And that's for a number of reasons. Firstly, you are going to feel more comfortable in a place you're familiar with, which is going to come in handy when we're talking about feeling at ease, right?
或者应该控制浪漫的场合，比如浪漫的连接。也许你喜欢这种付出，我不知道，我觉得这也完全没问题，但我坚信，即使他们选择了日期和时间，地点也由你来选。原因有很多。首先，你在熟悉的地方会感觉更舒服，这在我们讨论感到放松时会派上用场，对吧？
You are going to feel more at ease when you're meeting someone new if you already know where you're going and you know the place. we already have, you know, one thing unfamiliar that we need to adapt to, that is that new person. So let's just keep it to that. You know, let's just keep one thing unfamiliar. Number two, like we've said from the beginning, dating should be fun. So make it fun by going to a place you already know you enjoy so that even if it's like a shit night, the conversation is bad. At least you got to have your favorite drink or your favorite meal or choose your. favorite activity. My fail-proof equation. The place should be less than a 15-minute walk from your
当你遇到新的人时，如果你已经知道你要去哪里并且熟悉这个地方，你会感觉更自在。我们已经有了，你知道的，一个我们需要适应的不熟悉事物，那就是那个新的人。所以让我们保持这样就好。你知道的，让我们只保留一个不熟悉的事物。第二，就像我们从一开始就说过的那样，约会应该是有趣的。所以通过去一个你已经知道自己喜欢的地方来让它变得有趣，这样哪怕这是一次糟糕的夜晚，谈话很糟糕。至少你喝到了你最喜欢的饮料，吃到了你最喜欢的饭菜，或者选择了你最喜欢的活动。我百试百灵的公式。这个地方距离你家应该不到15分钟的步行路程。
house. There should be other places around where you could carry on with a second activity, so like another drink, some dessert, lunch, if it goes really well. And if it doesn't go well, you know, you're back home and under the hour, you don't need to commute across town. It's a 15-minute walk. Comfort, simplicity, familiarity. Those are all good signs of a first-date location. Okay, so next we need to get into the mindset of dating, and this is all about cultivating our confidence. Confidence, I cannot stress this enough, is like the secret ingredient to attractiveness. So they published this study in, I think it was the personality and social psychology journal, and they found that confidence is a huge predictor of overall romantic attractiveness and
周围应该有其他地方，如果进展真的很顺利，你可以继续进行第二次活动，比如再喝一杯、吃点甜点、吃午饭。如果进展不顺利，你知道的，你一个小时内就能回到家，你不需要跨城通勤。步行15分钟。舒适、简单、熟悉。这些都是第一次约会地点的良好迹象。好的，接下来我们需要进入约会的思维模式，这全关于培养我们的自信。自信，我怎么强调都不为过，就像是吸引力的秘密配料。所以他们在，我想是《人格与社会心理学期刊》上发表了这项研究，他们发现自信是整体浪漫吸引力和
desirability. It continuously tops the list of most desirable traits in a romantic partner, but it's also going to allow you to feel so much less anxious and it's going to let you be in your own power and really not care about the other person's opinion of you unless it's positive. You know, you like yourself and if they like you, it's an added bonus. It's that awareness of who you regardless of how someone else sees you, that is where our confidence comes from and that confidence, when you are comfortable with yourself, it grants you like a certain kind of charm, a certain kind of glow or assertiveness that makes people more secure around you. It, you know, makes your date feel better and the overall energy is also going to be better.
令人向往程度的一个巨大预测指标。它一直位居浪漫伴侣最渴望特质名单的前列，但它也会让你感到不那么焦虑，并让你掌握自己的力量，真正不在乎别人对你的看法，除非是正面的。你知道的，你喜欢你自己，如果他们也喜欢你，那就是个额外的红利。这种对自我的认知，不管别人怎么看你，这就是我们自信的来源，而当你对自己感到舒适时，这种自信会赋予你某种迷人的魅力、某种光芒或自信，让人在你身边感到更有安全感。它，你知道的，会让你的约会对象感觉更好，整体能量也会更好。
It makes you seem more attractive. Also, one of my friends said this to me the other day and I was like, Wow, that is such good advice. This person knows nothing about you. They know nothing about your past, about who you are. You get to be who you want to be. You get to write the narrative. So sometimes the secret to a confidence boost is just to fake it to you make it. And we can do that by boosting our pre-date mood. So don't wear what you think they'll like or try and predict their preferences. wear something that makes you feel good. Also, you need a pre-date pump-up playlist.
它让你看起来更有吸引力。另外，我的一个朋友前几天对我说这个，我当时想，哇，这真是太棒的建议了。这个人对你一无所知。他们对你的过去、你是谁一无所知。你可以成为你想成为的人。你可以编写剧本。所以有时重拾自信的秘诀就是“假装直到你成功”。我们可以通过提升约会前的心情来做到这一点。所以不要穿你认为他们会喜欢的衣服或去猜测他们的偏好。穿让你感觉良好的衣服。另外，你需要一个约会前的打气播放列表。
I used to have one. I'm going to try and remember what it's called. Oh, I think it was literally called buttlift. Like, buttlift. I don't know why, but music in these scenarios, especially like your hype songs, are going to flood your brain with dopamine. It's going to make you motivated, confident,
我以前有一个。我试着想想它叫什么。哦，我想它字面意思就叫提臀。就像，提臀。我不知道为什么，但是在这些场景中，尤其是你的嗨歌，会用多巴胺充斥你的大脑。它会让你充满动力、自信，
more alert. And if that isn't getting you there, leverage the power of affirmations, if you're still feeling really nervous, feeling like you kind of want to cancel last minute, affirmations really help reduce your self-limiting beliefs, your fears that maybe the date will suck, maybe they won't like you, maybe it will be a dud. And these affirmations shift that and put you into a mindset of confidence and openness. So these are some of my favorites, personally.
更加警觉。如果这还不够，如果你仍然感到非常紧张，觉得你有点想最后一刻取消，那就利用肯定句的力量，肯定句确实有助于减少你的自我限制信念，减少你对约会可能会砸、他们可能不会喜欢你、可能会是一场空欢喜的恐惧。这些肯定句改变了这一点，并将你带入自信和开放的心态。所以这些是我个人最喜欢的、
approved. I have used them many times. I used to repeat these like in the five minutes before I walked in the door. Tell yourself, I'm magnetic. I attract wonderful people into my life. I know who I am. I'm charismatic. I'm attractive. People are attracted to me. I know some people view the power of affirmations as a pseudoscience. Obviously, just saying these things doesn't quote uncle. quote, wish them into existence. But there is a lot of evidence that shows that the words we speak to ourselves influence the things we believe about ourselves, which in turn impacts our behaviour.
经过批准的。我用过很多次。我经常在进门前的五分钟重复这些话。告诉自己，我是有吸引力的。我吸引美好的人进入我的生活。我知道我是谁。我很有魅力。我很有吸引力。人们被我吸引。我知道有些人认为肯定句的力量是一种伪科学。很显然，仅仅说这些话并不能“祝”它们凭空出现。但有很多证据表明，我们对自己说的话会影响我们对自己的信念，进而影响我们的行为。
And it's those behaviours that create better first states. It's that assertiveness, that self-assurance, that it's going to make sure whatever happens that this person is going to walk away thinking that you definitely know your worth. and you're going to walk away being like, I had fun and I'm not too worried about that person's opinion. And if you're feeling nervous, I get the predate nerves. Just tell yourself you're excited by the feeling. You're excited by this feeling. You're not fearful. You are not anxious. Anxiety and excitement, they feel the same. So just tell yourself that it is that excitement that you're
正是这些行为创造了更好的第一次约会。正是那种自信、那种笃定，将确保无论发生什么，这个人离开时都会认为你绝对知道自己的价值，
feeling, not that nervousness. Finally, and this might be a little bit weird, but having a first date scent is such a hack, a scent that you only use on first dates. I know this sounds wild, but smell has a very unique influence on our brain, particularly our olfactory cortex and the olfactory bulb, which is at the front of the brain. And smell can be used to cue behaviors and cue a mindset. It is associated with memories that you can tune into and a sense of like, almost like a purpose. Like if you associate a smell with good things, if you associate a smell with feeling confident, that's going to mean that when you smell that scent, that is going to be activated. This scent is kind of also going to activate your first date patterns. It's going to
而你离开时会觉得，我很开心，而且我不太担心那个人的看法。如果你感到紧张，我理解约会前的紧张。只要告诉自己，你对这种感觉感到兴奋。你对这种感觉感到兴奋。你不是害怕。你不是焦虑。焦虑和兴奋，它们感觉是一样的。所以只要告诉自己，你感受到的是那种兴奋，而不是那种紧张。最后，这可能有点奇怪，但有一个第一次约会的专属香水真是一个绝招，一种你只在第一次约会时才使用的香味。我知道这听起来很疯狂，但气味对我们的大脑有着非常独特的影响，特别是我们的嗅觉皮层和位于大脑前部的嗅球。气味可以用来触发行为和触发思维模式。它与你可以调谐的记忆有关，并且有一种类似于目的感的东西。如果你把气味与美好的事物联系起来，如果你把气味与自信的感觉联系起来，这意味着当你闻到那种香味时，它就会被激活。这种香味也有点会激活你的第一次约会模式。它会
make you feel more calm. It's going to put you in the mind frame of like, I'm going to go on this date. It's going to be fun. This is my first date scent. I'm locked in. I'm excited. And that smell also has a unique influence on your date as well, particularly through its influence on pheromones. So our perception of kind of like a potential partner's body odor, whether it is sweet or rich or musky, whatever, it will subconsciously influence attraction. So when we smell something pleasant, our body responds by producing hormones and chemicals in our body that tell us to rest and relax, but also neurotransmitters like oxytotransmitters like oxytocin that act on the pleasure centers of our brain. So when you're attracted to someone,
让你感到更平静。它会让你进入这样一种心态：我要去约会了。这会很有趣。这是我的第一次约会香水。我锁定状态了。我很兴奋。而且这种气味对你的约会对象也有独特的影响，特别是通过它对信息素的影响。因此，我们对潜在伴侣体味的看法，无论是甜的、浓郁的还是麝香的等等，都会潜移默化地影响吸引力。所以当我们闻到令人愉悦的气味时，我们的身体会通过在体内产生荷尔蒙和化学物质来做出反应，这些荷尔蒙和化学物质告诉我们要休息和放松，还有神经递质，如催产素等，它们作用于我们大脑的快乐中心。所以当你被一个人吸引时，
you're more likely to be drawn to their smell. So sometimes just knowing that you smell good, gives you a boost. Knowing that smells associated with attraction makes you be like, all right, I'm already one step ahead. This person is going to like me just because I smell nice. You'll feel more attractive. You'll feel more appealing. And you'll act accordingly. So those are my tips for before, text less, location, comfort, confidence and smell, all of which are going to help you relax those first date jitters. But what we're going to talk about next is during the date. And during the date, there's two things that we want to focus on. Body language and conversation, sometimes even the absence of conversation. I think we often focus too much on worrying whether we'll have enough to talk
你更有可能被他们的气味所吸引。所以有时候，仅仅知道自己闻起来很香，就能给你带来动力。知道气味与吸引力有关，会让你觉得，好吧，我已经领先一步了。这个人会喜欢我，只因为我闻起来很好闻。你会觉得自己更有吸引力。你会觉得自己更有魅力。并且你也会随之表现出来。所以这些是我关于约会前的建议，少发短信、地点、舒适度、自信和气味，所有这些都将有助于你缓解第一次约会的紧张情绪。但我们接下来要谈的是约会期间。在约会期间，我们要关注两件事。肢体语言和对话，有时甚至是对话的缺席。我想我们经常把太多精力放在担心我们是否有足够的话题上，
about rather than what we are going to get out of this experience, what we are ready to learn about ourselves, but also about the other person. And that energy, that chemistry, that attraction flows not just through conversation, but also through our non-verbal cues. Obviously, conversation is important. You know, what's a date without one? You're kind of just staring at each other for a couple of hours. Intimate, not very fun. My friend Erin, though, always says, the five like easiest topics to talk about on a first date are friends, family, work, hobbies, and the week. That will cover, that will cover you for at least an hour. So you don't have to be afraid that you're not going to have anything to say. And sometimes not having anything to say is a
而不是我们能从这段经历中得到什么，我们准备好了解自己什么，以及了解另一个人什么。这种能量、化学反应、吸引力不仅通过对话流动，还通过我们的非语言线索流动。显然，对话很重要。你知道的，没有对话算什么约会？你们只是互相盯着看几个小时。亲密，但一点也不好玩。不过我的朋友埃林总是说，第一次约会上最容易聊的五个话题是朋友、家人、工作、爱好和这一周。这能涵盖，这能让你聊至少一个小时。所以你不必担心自己会无话可说。有时候无话可说其实是一个
pretty clear indicator that this person is probably not right for you. So don't be afraid of that silence. I think sometimes when we are nervous, we bombard someone. with questions. We try and fill the silence. We don't really listen to their answers and there's no connection from that. So instead of thinking ahead, instead of trying to plan what you're going to say, accept that silence is actually important. Silence is kind of like a secret weapon because we know it builds suspense. And suspense builds intrigue, it builds anticipation, it builds excitement. And that will keep someone engaged in the date. Honestly, like, not to sound too deliberate, but I used to make a conscious choice to pause between every like three or four questions, not just to give
非常明确的指标，表明这个人可能不适合你。所以不要害怕这种沉默。我想有时当我们紧张时，我们会用问题轰炸某人。我们试图填补沉默。我们并没有真正听取他们的回答，也没有从中建立连接。所以与其提前考虑，与其试图计划你要说的话，不如接受沉默其实很重要。沉默有点像秘密武器，因为我们知道它能营造悬念。而悬念能建立好奇心、建立期待、建立兴奋感。并且那会让人一直投入到约会中。说实话，听起来可能有点太刻意了，但我过去常常有意识地在每三四个问题之间停顿一下，不仅是为了给
someone else space to speak, which I think is important. But also when someone is waiting for you to speak next, they're interested. You have their attention. And that attention between both of you makes for a good first date. And now let's start. talk about body cues as well. Like I said, it's not just having a good chat. It's in the body. It's in the nonverbal communication. That speaks volumes. And you can tune into that to draw someone in to create more of that kind of intimacy and closeness and engagement. The first one is eye contact. Prolonged eye contact releases a stimulant in our brain that brings focus. It brings happiness. It's often associated with feelings of attraction. It's also been
别人说话的空间，我认为这很重要。而且当别人在等你接话时，他们是有兴趣的。你吸引了他们的注意力。双方的这种注意力促成了一次美好的第一次约会。现在让我们开始。也谈谈身体线索。就像我说的，这不仅仅是进行一次愉快的聊天。它体现在身体里。它体现在非语言沟通中。那说明了很多问题。你可以通过调谐来吸引某人，创造更多那种亲密感、紧密感和投入感。第一个是眼神交流。长时间的眼神交流会释放出一种刺激物，集中我们的注意力。它带来快乐。它通常与吸引力的感觉有关。它也被
thought to release, once again, oxytocin, the love chemical, which is important for long-term bonding. It's because the eyes, our eyes, they're vulnerable. It's where we see emotion. And when we continue to draw someone back to that feature, back to that part of our face, the level of contact feels deeper. Mirroring is also pretty powerful. So I don't know if you've heard about mirroring before, but it's essentially this technique where we copy the other person's body language to indicate attentiveness and interest. Obviously, golden rules still be yourself in those moments, but when we kind of copy someone else's behavior, if they lean forward, we lean forward, if they cross their arms, we cross our arms, that acts on a specific set of nerve cells called mirror neurons. So one common
再次释放出催产素，也就是所谓的“爱之化学物质”，这对建立长期的亲密关系非常重要。这是因为眼睛，我们的眼睛是很脆弱的。那是我们流露出情感的地方。当我们继续把别人的注意力吸引到那个特征上，吸引到我们脸部的那个部位时，接触的程度就会感觉更深。镜像效应也非常强大。所以，我不知道你以前是否听说过镜像效应，但它本质上是一种这样的技术：我们模仿对方的肢体语言来表示专注和兴趣。显然，黄金法则依然是：在那些时刻做你自己。但当我们有点像在模仿别人的行为时，如果他们向前倾，我们就向前倾；如果他们交叉双臂，我们也交叉双臂，这就会对一套被称为镜像神经元的特定神经细胞起作用。所以，一个常见的
situation occurs when, you know, someone else laughs. Scientists have found that the brain responds to the sound of laughter to also prepare the muscles in our face and our vocal cords to laugh in response. Other examples of kind of mirroring or mimicking behaviors includes crossing your legs after someone you're sitting next to does that. Or, you know, when we yawn after seeing someone else yawn, even if we have no intention of doing it, even if we had no sense that we needed to yawn before, it's this really kind of powerful automatic tool that sometimes happens without us being aware of it, that when we are attracted to someone, when we're connected to someone, we're engaged with someone, we are drawn to mimic their behavior to show that we trust them and to show that we are not a threat.
情况发生在，你知道的，当别人笑的时候。科学家发现，大脑对笑声的反应也会让面部肌肉和声带做好准备，从而报以微笑。其他属于镜像或模仿行为的例子还包括：在坐在你旁边的人翘起二郎腿后，你也跟着翘起二郎腿。或者，你知道的，当我们看到别人打哈欠时，自己也会跟着打哈欠，哪怕我们根本没有想去打哈欠，哪怕在此之前我们完全没有觉得需要打哈欠。这是一种非常强大的、有时会在我们不知情的情况下发生的自动工具：当我们被某人吸引时，当我们与某人建立联系时，当我们与某人互动时，我们会不由自主地去模仿他们的行为，以此来表明我们信任他们，并证明我们对他们不构成威胁。
Okay, so during the date, rely on those nonverbal communication skills, lean in, make eye contact, mirror and also kind of unrelated. If it's not going well, I cannot stress this enough, just leave. Leave. Remember, we are adopting a low-stakes attitude, a low-stakes approach. And we don't want any negative associations between a first date and not having fun, or feeling drained or bored. You don't need to be polite or worry about offending their feeling. by doing what's best for you, I think that level of self-assurance, like, no, this isn't going
好了，所以在约会期间，要依靠那些非语言沟通技巧，身体前倾，进行眼神交流，注意镜像模仿，还有一点，这似乎有点无关。如果约会进展不顺，怎么强调都不为过：直接走开。离开。记住，我们要采取低风险的态度，低风险的方法。我们不希望第一次约会与不开心、精疲力竭或无聊之间产生任何负面联系。你不需要表现得礼貌，也不用担心会冒犯对方的感受。通过做对自己最好的事，我认为那种自信的程度——比如“不，这进行得不顺利”
well, I'm not here for this, I'm not having fun. It really sets you up to be more discerning in the future. It lets you reinforce your own self-worth, reinforce your own confidence, your own decision-making, and it stops you from wasting your time. I think normally we try and avoid that because we want other people to like us, or we want to not come off as rude. but you are there for an experience the same way that they are. And if the experience is not one that you are enjoying, you can just leave. I think that's a really important reminder. So finally, normally when the date is done, we think, okay, well, the date's done.
“我不是来受这个罪的，我一点也不开心”——真的能让你在未来更有鉴别力。它能让你巩固自己的自我价值，巩固你自己的自信和决策能力，并且能阻止你浪费时间。我认为通常我们会尽量避免这样做，因为我们希望别人喜欢我们，或者我们不想显得粗鲁。但你和他们一样，也是为了体验而去的。如果这段体验并不是你所享受的，你完全可以一走了之。我认为这是一个非常重要的提醒。所以最后，通常在约会结束时，我们会想：“好吧，约会结束了。”
You know, either I'm going to get a text back or we kind of move on to the next. But I actually think the secret to having better first dates in your 20s comes from what you do after as much as what you do before and during the date. So we are going to explore all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
你知道的，要么我会收到回信，要么我们就进入下一个目标。但实际上我认为，在你二十多岁时拥有更好的第一次约会的秘诀，很大程度上取决于你在约会之后做了什么，这和你在约会前以及约会期间做的事同样重要。所以，在经历这段短暂的广告之后，我们将探讨所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等人展开对话，带大家看透那些主导健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们真的曾以为植物油天生就会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是可在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听的《2%》。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down,
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两下小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在播客节目《回看当年》（Look Back at It）中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so.
我是亚历克斯·英格利斯（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何撑过那段时期的。其中包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅聊80年代快克毒品的节目。为了说清楚，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。顺便一提，我随时都可以聊聊快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们第二集讨论快克了，所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆上台面了，所以。
Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
然后你把那句话说完。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《回看当年》。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬着头皮学》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid?
有时，当我们去追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐的过程中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分板。生活变成了一场关于胜利与失败的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你们觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人，是因为你心存恐惧吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地、纯粹地去当一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《硬着头皮学》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《硬着头皮学》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己身处一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregal Westby and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的前后矛盾。这就开启了一场长达数年的、旨在证明真相的法庭之战。“你在欧文斯（Owens）伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次测试。”这需要一支由网络侦探组成的队伍来破解这个案件。“我希望人们能看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。”阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷加尔·韦斯特比（Gregal Westby）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trap）。“劳拉，斯科茨戴尔警方。”随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If there is one thing, I believe more than anything else, when it comes to dating, it's that first impressions are not always correct. Some people may say, you know, when you know you know, know, but I think there are a lot of other factors there. And if you're treating dating like a fulfilling experience, like something fun, sometimes you actually need to do a bit of review on how you're feeling about the person afterwards and why that is. When you were around them,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县（Maricopa County）突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。如果说关于约会有什么是我坚信不移的，那就是第一印象并不总是准确的。有些人可能会说，你知道的，当你懂的时候自然就懂了，但我认为其中还有很多其他的因素。如果你把约会当作一次充实的体验、一件有趣的事情，有时你其实真的需要花点时间回顾一下，事后你对这个人是什么感觉，以及为什么会有这种感觉。当你和他们在一起时，
did you feel comfortable? Did you actually enjoy yourself? And most importantly, was it actually a good date? Are they actually fun? Do you want to be around them? Or are you just fun? Are you just interesting. Are you just a really fun person to date? And so it makes them seem more interesting. I found that all the time when I was single, because I had such a good attitude to this, that this is exciting. I'm keen to see what's out there and actually have a good time. I really curated and created situations and dates that were going to make the other person seem fun no matter what. And sometimes that created a first impression and they actually just weren't. that way in the future. Like when I got to know them more, it wasn't correct. So really ask yourself,
你觉得自在吗？你真的玩得开心吗？最重要的是，这真的算是一次好约会吗？他们真的有趣吗？你想和他们待在一起吗？还是说，只是因为你很有趣？你只是很有趣而已。你只是一个非常适合约会的人，所以这让他们看起来也更有趣。当我单身时，我一直都有这种感觉，因为我对这事儿抱有极好的心态——我觉得这很令人兴奋。我很想看看外面都有什么样的人，并且真正度过一段美好的时光。我精心策划并创造了各种情境和约会，无论如何都要让对方显得很有趣。有时这会制造出一种第一印象，但实际上他们未来并不是那样的人。就像当我更深入地了解他们之后，那种第一印象并不准确。所以一定要问问你自己：
did they ask you questions about yourself? Was that fake laughter or real laughter? How many times did you check your phone or did you check the time? Those can tell you a lot more about a date than your gut feeling. And I think if you're not sure, honestly, sometimes I would actually just say go on the second date if they're up for it because chances are that. that your first impression was based on a lot of factors that you can't really control. It's based on nerves. It's based on how you're feeling about yourself. And it can't always be trusted. I have a story for you about this. After my first date with my boyfriend, I was like honestly convinced that I wasn't going to see him again because he gave me like no romantic signals.
他们有没有问过你关于你自己的问题？那是假笑还是真笑？你看了多少次手机或者看了多少次时间？比起你的直觉，这些更能说明这次约会的情况。而且我认为如果你不确定，说实话，有时我真的会建议：如果对方也有意愿，那就去进行第二次约会吧，因为很有可能……你的第一印象是基于很多你无法真正控制的因素。它是基于紧张情绪。它是基于你对自己的感觉。而且它并不总是值得信赖的。关于这一点，我和你们分享一个故事。在我跟男友的第一次约会后，老实说，我当时确信自己不会再见他了，因为他几乎没有给我任何浪漫的暗示。
I know we had a good first date, but I was like, why do I feel almost bored? Like I have no anxiety. And I realized that was because he was one of the first people I'd gone on a date with where I had no expectations in advance. I had no anxiety. And I think that's, that anxiety is often what we confuse as chemistry. And even though I was unsure of our first impression, it was the sense of like, I had fun and I was at peace. And yet I feel like this isn't exciting enough, but that's because like all those other previous situations, all those other first dates like gone on, I was like constantly trying to create situations in which we were having like the best time ever, rather than just letting myself relax. And I went on a second day. I'm so glad that I did. Second dates
我知道我们第一次约会很愉快，但我就在想：为什么我几乎感觉有点无聊？就像我一点焦虑都没有。我意识到，那是因为他是和我约会过的人当中，少数几个让我事先没有任何期望的人之一。我没有任何焦虑。我认为这种焦虑往往就是我们所混淆的“来电的感觉”（化学反应）。尽管我对我们的第一印象不太确定，但那种感觉就像是：我玩得很开心，而且我很平静。然而我觉得这还不够刺激，但那是因为像之前所有那些情况一样，像我之前去过的所有其他第一次约会一样，我一直在试图营造一种我们正在度过“有史以来最美好的时光”的情境，而不是让自己放松下来。后来我去了第二次约会。我太高兴我这么做了。第二次约会
are always, I think, so much better and more meaningful and also are going to give you more information about that person because it's like a lot of us have like that first date veneer, like that first date kind of facade. And we have our like practiced first date stories. We're trying to put on a really good image for someone. The second date, that kind of comes down a little bit. Instant chemistry is also, I think, not the most important thing here. I think we've been sold this really weird narrative around love that meant, you know,
我一直认为要好得多、更有意义，而且它会为你提供关于那个人的更多信息，因为这就好像我们很多人都带着第一次约会的面具，带着一种第一次约会的伪装。我们带着我们练习好的、关于第一次约会的那些故事。我们试图在某人面前展现一个非常好的形象。而到了第二次约会，那种伪装就会稍微卸下一部分。我认为，瞬间的化学反应在这里也不是最重要的事情。我觉得我们被灌输了一种关于爱情的、非常奇怪的叙事，这意味着……
that when you meet the one or whatever it is, it's meant to be instantaneous and there will be sparks and butterflies and passion straight off the bat. Not always true. Intimacy and connection and chemistry are things that build over time. So don't always trust your first date self to make those decisions. I think post-date also don't be afraid to text them first. Honestly, fuck the rules. Fuck the games.
当你遇到真命天子或真命天女时，一切本该是电光石火般的瞬间发生，立刻就会有火花、小鹿乱撞的感觉以及激情。事实并非总是如此。亲密感、联系和化学反应是随着时间推移而建立起来的东西。所以，不要总是盲目相信第一次约会的那个自己来做这些决定。我认为在约会结束后，也不要害怕先给对方发信息。说实话，去他的规则。去他的博弈。
Do what feels best without trying to second-guess your intentions or, you know, you don't want to come off too strong. I just think that's ridiculous. You know, you're in this for you. So call the shots. And I think if you really like them, being like, let's do that again. And getting no response, that is a response in itself or getting a positive response is a green flag.
做感觉最自然的事，不要去试图过度揣摩你的意图，或者觉得……你不想表现得过于主动。我只是觉得这太荒谬了。你知道的，你这么做是为了你自己。所以，掌握主动权。而且我认为如果你真的很喜欢他们，直接说“我们再约一次吧”。如果收不到回复，那本身就是一个回复；而如果收到积极的回复，就是一个好兆头。
Like, at least you cut the games. At least you get it out of the way. You don't have to like constantly be judging what this other person thinks. Like, I'm going to say it again. You are in this for you, so you should call the shots. So this episode has all been about having really good first dates, maybe the best first dates of your life, maybe never needing to go on a first date again because you use these tips and you found them on. But bad dates are also unfortunately unavoidable. You've got to kiss a few frogs as they say. Some people are just not compatible because of their values, their intentions, their personality.
至少你打破了那些心理博弈。至少你把它抛在了脑后。你不需要总是去揣测另一个人在想什么。我要再说一遍：你这么做是为了你自己，所以你应该掌握主动权。所以这一集全部都是关于如何拥有非常棒的第一次约会，也许是你人生中最棒的第一次约会，也许由于你使用了这些小贴士并找到了对的人，你再也不需要去进行什么第一次约会了。但遗憾的是，糟糕的约会也是不可避免的。正如人们所说，你必须先吻过几只青蛙。有些人由于价值观、意图、性格的不同，就是合不来。
And we can sometimes find that, you know, really exhausting. Really, really exhausting if you've just gone on so many. any dates with people and it just didn't work out and you're at the end of your tether. But I'd say don't let the bad dates scare you away from beautiful experiences and moments in the future. We often feel the need after a bad first date to do one of two things. A, we immediately feel like we need to run out and go on another date right away. Like we want to cleanse the palette and like forget the bad memory, eat something like tasty after something foul. I think that when we do that we don't remember what our intentions are. We are more wanting to distract ourselves
有时我们会发现，你知道的，这真的很累人。如果你刚和很多人约过会，却发现根本行不通，而且你已经筋疲力尽了，那真的、真的很累人。但我想说的是，不要让糟糕的约会让你的未来对美好的经历和时刻望而却步。在经历了一次糟糕的第一次约会后，我们通常会觉得有必要做两件事之一。A，我们立刻觉得需要冲出去，马上开始另一场约会。就好像我们想要清理一下味蕾，忘掉那个糟糕的记忆，在吃了一些糟糕的东西之后再吃点美味的。我认为当我们这样做时，我们就忘记了自己的初衷。我们更多的是想转移注意力，
from what was probably maybe a bad experience. B, I think the second thing we do is engage in the fallacy that this one bad date is somehow predictive that our next date will also be bad. That is not the case. That person's behaviors and personality, whatever it was that was unattractive, they have no correlation to what the next person will be like. So don't love. let that experience control your behavior or your dating life beyond what happened in that one evening or on that one date. Something I always say is it's just a good story. It's kind of like do it for the plot. But when we reframe bad, uncomfortable experiences into something that we can see is slightly positive, you know that we're going to get a good personal anecdote from this
不去想那可能是一次糟糕的经历。B，我认为我们做的第二件事是陷入这样一种谬论：这一次糟糕的约会某种程度上预示着我们的下一次约会也会很糟糕。事实并非如此。那个人的行为和性格，无论是什么让人反感的地方，都和下一个人会是什么样没有任何关联。所以不要让……不要让那次经历控制你的行为或你的约会生活，超出那一晚或那一次约会所发生的事情。我常说的一句话是：这不过是个好故事。这有点像“为了情节去经历”。但当我们把糟糕、不舒服的经历重新定义为我们可以从中看到一点点积极意义的事情时，你知道的，我们能从中得到一个不错的个人趣闻，或者至少我们的朋友会觉得这很有趣。我们是在潜意识里运用心理学家所称的认知行为训练或疗法。我们正在改变我们对某个事件或情况的想法或态度，使其变得更加积极，这样我们就不会让我们的感知打乱我们未来的行为。我们不会让它导致未来的回避行为。另一件非常普遍的事情就是“人间蒸发”（ghosting）。而且你知道的，如果他们在第一次约会后对你玩失踪，比起你的价值，这更能说明他们情感上的不可得。记住在那些时刻……你是谁。你绝对是个抢手货。
or that at least our friends will find it funny. We are implicitly using what psychologists call cognitive behavioral training or therapy. We are altering our thoughts or our attitudes towards an event or a situation to be more positive so that we don't let our perception interrupt our future behavior. We don't let it create future avoidance. Another thing that is really common is ghosting. And you know, if they ghost you after your first date, that says more about their emotional unavailability than anything about your value. Remember who. who the hell you are in those moments. You are an absolute catch.
你是极具吸引力的。你爱得深沉。你才华横溢、善良聪慧。能和hé你在一起是那个人的荣幸。我为他们错失良机感到遗憾。这对他们来说太令人失望了。祝他们好运吧。所以他们可以继续去寻找，而他们送给你的礼物是……
You are magnetic. You love deeply. You are talented and kind and intelligent. It would have been a privilege for that person to be with you. And I feel sorry for them that they lost out. That's so disappointing for them. Bad luck to them. And so they can go on searching and what they've given you as a gift.
他们送给你的礼物是放手让你离开，让你去寻找更好的人。好了，这些信息信息量太大了。你们能看出我有多为这个话题感到兴奋了吧。我喜欢通过你们来体验生活。我喜欢通过我的朋友们来体验生活。我希望你们所有人都能有棒极了的第一次约会，并且我希望你们把这些告诉。但我首先，让我们再过一遍那些小贴士。首先，限制发信息。
They've given you the gift of letting you go, of letting you find someone better. Okay, so this was information overload. You can tell I was excited for this topic. I love living vicariously through you guys. I love living vicariously through my friends. I want you all to have amazing first dates and I want you to tell me about them. But firstly, let's run through those tips again. First of all, limit the texting.
选择地点并主动出击。把自信和舒适放在首位。记住你是谁，并为自己重新确认这一点。选择你的香水、你的气味，让自己进入那种心态。把你的焦虑当作兴奋。记住，这并不完全取决于对话。它也关乎沉默。
Choose the location and make the move. Prioritize confidence and comfort. Remember who you are. and reaffirm that for yourself. Choose your scent, your smell to get you into the mindset. Treat your anxiety like excitement. Remember that it's not all about conversation. It's also about silence.
它也关乎悬念。确保你运用了你的肢体语言，进行眼神交流，模仿他们的行为。并对自己进行复盘。我怎样才能把这事做得更好？我怎样才能让自己更享受？这是我想要的那种人吗？还是不是。并且不要让糟糕的约会拖你的后腿。有时在我们二十多岁的时候，这确实有点像是一场数字游戏。这有点像是一个不断试错的过程。如果你正在寻找的话，你最终会找到某人的。
It's also about suspense. Make sure you use your body language, make eye contact, mirror their behavior. And debrief with yourself. How could I make this better? How could I enjoy myself more? Is this the kind of person I want? or not. And also don't let the bad dates hold you back. Sometimes in our 20s, it is a little bit of a numbers game. It is a little bit of trial and error. You'll find someone eventually if that's what
而且在这个过程中你会玩得很开心。就像我在这一集里说过一百万次的那样，约会本来就应该是开心的。它不应该成为一件苦差事。它不应该成为一件你必须强迫自己去做的事，你应当为有机会结识所有这些新朋友并为自己创造故事而感到兴奋。所以我真的希望这一集对所有那些正在积极约会、将自己展现出来的美丽听众们有所帮助。我太喜欢这样了！这正是你二十多岁时该做的事：享受乐趣、结识新朋友、在实践中不断尝试。所以我很想知道你是否使用了这些小贴士，我想听听你们的第一次约会，我想和大家复盘。伙计们，我很享受恋爱关系，但我的内心深处，我怀念那种单身时的刺激感。
you're looking for. And you'll have fun in the process. Like I said, a million times in this episode, dating is meant to be fun. It's not meant to be a chore. It's not meant to be something you have to force yourself to do you should be excited by the opportunity to meet all these new people and create stories for yourself so i really hope that this episode has been helpful for all of my beautiful listeners out there putting themselves out there dating up a storm i freaking love it that is what your 20s are all about having fun meeting people testing things out as you go so i want to know if you use any of these tips i want to hear about your first dates i want to debrief guys i love being in a relationship, but some part of me, I miss the excitement of like being single.
就像我不怀念那种焦虑感一样。我想这就是“邻家的草总是更绿”吧，对吧？就像你总是……你知道的，在经历结束后，你总是会想起那些当时没有意识到是积极面的事情。所以请让我知道你们的约会进展如何，你们是否使用了这些小贴士，它们是否成功了。像往常一样，我真的希望你们喜欢这一集。如果你们生命中有谁需要听听这些，请随时分享给他们，如果在Instagram上分享的话也别忘了@我们。你们可以在That Psychology Podcast关注我们。如果你对未来的某一集节目有什么建议，如果你有什么反馈，如果你只是想取得联系，如果你想聊聊天，
Like I don't miss the anxiety. I think it's like the grass is always greener, right? Like you're always like looking, you know, after the experience is done, you always remember the things that at the time you didn't realize were positive. So please let me know how your dates are going, whether you use these tips if they were successful. And as always, I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. If there is someone in your life who needs to hear this, please feel free to share it with them and tag us on Instagram if you're sharing it there as well. You can follow us at that psychology podcast. If you have a future suggestion for an episode, if you have some feedback, if you just want to get in touch, if you want to have a chat,
我们随时欢迎。当然，我们周五会带着另一集节目回归。所以我们到时见。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
all is welcome over there. And of course, we will be back on Friday for another episode. So we will see you then. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是可在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听的《2%》。在《回看当年》播客中，从1979年开始，那对对我来说是个大时刻。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at a Podcast, From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
84对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何撑过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。
84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《回看当年》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）主持的《硬着头皮学》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
进行那些在其他地方根本不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人背负着铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《硬着头皮学》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个恶作剧。“你在欧文斯伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次测试。”
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or web, you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones.
这需要一支由网络侦探组成的队伍来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷（Greg）、莱斯利（Lesbian）。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱的陷阱》。“劳拉，斯科茨戴尔警方。”
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人出品。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的播出，劳拉·欧文斯最终受到了惩罚。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《被困的爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人制作，品质保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。